uh watch the foreign objects if you're
gonna fight pac-man jones yeah he's got
some stories
watch the foreign objects if you're
gonna follow through with a pass don't
bang your hand against a helmet that's
what cam newton did on friday left early
it's a slight bone bruise according to
nfl media quite possibly we won't see
him anymore in the spring it opened the
door for mac jones to come in and
perform and chris mike reese of espn.com
pointed out that
jones badly missed some throws yeah
after that and jared stidham actually
looked pretty good i don't know what any
of it means but one of joan's strongest
suits is his accuracy and all of a
sudden he gets thrust into the spotlight
and the accuracy wasn't there no i'm not
surprised to hear that i'm not you know
again you get thrust into the spotlight
oh wait now you're taking reps at maybe
against the first team defense who's
doing things some schematically that are
a little more advanced than the second
and third team defense you're facing
against or you're running a play that's
you know hey cam newton's been here it's
a little more advanced you don't
understand it quite yet you weren't
really supposed to run this today you
were supposed to run these plays but now
you got to do this it's a little more
advanced he's off kilter there it's not
shocking to hear and like this is the
great thing about new england mike
unlike other teams too
they don't they don't script for success
they don't go like oh hey you know we're
gonna run this play on play four and hey
defensive coordinator can you play this
defense so we can get a nice completion
and get some rhythm going they don't do
that the defense gets the call whatever
they want and they go execute the damn
offensive play and figure out how to do
that and that can lead to some tougher
times than most other teams on that uh
on the offensive side of the ball so it
was a shock to hear that
i'm fascinated by the competition that
is going to play out because it will be
as we've said before something that is
resolved based on merit and i know chris
you've said
that bill belichick likes to have one
quarterback who leads the team but when
you look at newton and jones the skill
set's so different right
will there be temptation
to make a decision week by week based
upon the defense they expect to face i i
i i can't imagine belichick doing it but
if anyone can pull it off it's him no it
is i mean again it's like something i
don't expect
but
you never know what to expect with
belichick and the patriots and
they're always well thought if they were
to do it they'd have a real rhyme or
reason to why they think it can work and
also realizing the two personalities
involved in the situation would be able
to make it work too and all of that type
of stuff so if they were to do that they
would have a real reason but uh yeah and
at least in my history i don't envision
that so we'll see where that goes
but i wasn't surprised to hear that cam
newton throwing hand hitting on a helmet
happens a lot i would bet you that's the
end of him through otas here it's you
know can be hard to grip the ball once
you bruise that hand like that
indulge me on this though because i
think for the patriots the season begins
week four when tom brady comes to town
you've got the dolphins you've got the
jets right you've got the saints the
first three weeks could we see
bill belichick deliberately and
strategically say
mac jones is getting one of those three
starts and then it's all part of the
total evaluation to decide who plays
week four when the bucks come to town i
don't think so i think he's gonna want
like
his team full speed ahead rolling
hitting on all cylinders we know who we
are we have a planned attack behind one
guy when it gets to that week four
instead of like oh we've done this good
and we've done that good and okay this
one was a little bit better than that
one so let's start to me that's that's
not in new england's dna they're more
about we're going to build something
we're going to become really good at
this we're going to become so good at it
that you're going to have to put more
than you know one egg in that you know
in that box to stop it that's a
simpsonism i think uh but either way
you're gonna have to stop and then they
go off of that that's to me where i
think you know the beauty of new england
is they kind of get an
mo or identity to their offense and they
make you stop that and then their
mcdaniels gets creative off of that and
that that's where i would envision it
going
yeah i think one in the one egg in the
box is up there with megahorn today yes
it is i don't know what the hell i was
trying to say there
yeah i never do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports